[Music]
in sneaky Apple loose that's thinking
nose sneaky I like you're about to start
wrapping it evil queen how do you be a
sneaky Apple no think in New York sneaky
people in New York maybe I'm going too
deep submitted by hot cakes cupcakes
weren't worth what area does call Mexico
case hockey is just the old-fashioned
term terrible Apple is now facing
lawsuits for purposely or secretly
slowing down older iPhones [ __ ] Apple
you didn't know that well they would
tell me that but I'm just like no is
just the wear and tear of the equipment
that you've got I got my apples back but
now what the [ __ ] everybody I gotta
Jordan they did it to do it five years I
felt I think the other one does that
you know they let it's proven that they
have materials to have tires I last
forever but they purposely make it worse
in horrors it doesn't make sense for
Toyota to make a car that last eighty
hundred thousand miles yeah they want
you to buy a new car every couple of
years come on so it's like it's long
this is they just make you more sick the
man they're holding this down then how
does JanSport backpack make money
because those [ __ ] never ruin our
business they are really pearls no no
because maybe because they've only had
one students every year we just saw them
at agenda they're coming out with some
new new [ __ ] it's really dope what do
you sponsored Maidan sport get off it
look at Herschel the Herschel smashing
on JanSport personal calls important to
know all any wise business marketing yes
jazz boy who's been around since we were
in junior high that was the mascot
Herschel's market sir that's for that
don't work for the [ __ ] marketing
company that knows a market share
Herschel is smashed
it's because it's like trendy you know
JanSport is like tried-and-true
old-school never hold on brendi [ __ ]
that falls apart that's the key to
business yeah yeah so now Apple is
facing more than 30 lawsuits after 30
that's it it's illegal like where groups
it's for many states do you think a
billion people would just be suing
they're after some cash it's expected
but it's also it just feels unethical
because it's like you're wasting so much
[ __ ] but they need to do it because of
consumerism you know like that's how
they stay in business I think like with
the phone even less so than like
backpacks like a backpacks and I'm gonna
change your who's gonna push it and
that's what it does like eventually some
of them have a laptop sleep we get out
of here if you have iPhones if you have
iPhone 6 and it's still working fast
eventually you're gonna want a better
camera or better apps like eventually
you're gonna do it we're a JanSport if
it never breaks you're gonna keep that
[ __ ] yeah so that they don't have to do
it as much as another industry yeah then
these lawsuits are accusing the company
of intentionally slowing down old red
phones oh yeah my shits Louis [ __ ] now
what do you I bumped by Bor six what the
[ __ ] Wow no this has to be a 66 it's a
six you get the button you press the
button yeah it's a bat oh yeah it's
paroled there we accused of that or
failing to disclose power management
changes with update ten point two point
one so with that update what they were
doing is they were pretty much
intentionally pushing iOS okay wonder I
[ __ ] update it and then you got slow
because before that I was fine yeah so
they are imposing performance demands on
the phones that can't handle that
performance slowing it down so like the
reason why they're getting sued is
because Apple hid this from people like
they they hid the fact that you can fix
your phone by replacing the battery it
all came to light when a reddit user
he pretty much went viral when he showed
that
along with performance statistics that
replacing his battery on his phone
and made his phone significantly faster
so that's all I got to do is replace
this battery yeah yeah so then now
because of all this it's coming to light
Apple is they issued an apology wowie we
got cops yeah and then so this is what
they said but our goal is to deliver the
best experience for customers which
includes overall performance and
prolonging the life of their devices
lithium-ion batteries become less
capable of supplying peak current
demands when in cold conditions have a
low battery charge or as they age over
time which can result in the device
unexpectedly shutting down to protective
electronic components last year we
released a feature for iPhone 6 iPhone
6s and iPhone se to smooth out the
instantaneous peaks only when needed to
prevent the device from unexpectedly
shutting down during these conditions
we've now extended that feature to
iPhone 7 with iOS 11.2 and plan to add
support for other products in the future
so then now if they really cared about
that they would be like a car where it's
like recommended swap out the [ __ ]
you know Bell or whatever with 100,000
miles yeah or like whatever they would
they would do that for phone you
recommend it to change your battery
every year or every how many hours of
use yeah so like these lawsuits they
want Apple to make it clear that taking
your phone and to get your battery
replaced will regain the performance and
so keep banging here is the fact that
you do not need to buy a new phone
that's the whole bottom line here the
fact that they hid that from people like
me like I think you bought a brand new
phone because of that reason my phone
kept shutting down every time I kept
trying to use it I'm like what the hell
I couldn't even respond a text messages
I couldn't do anything so that's the
reason why I got a new phone and just
she's weird knowing now this should have
like just came out
it's $1,000 a 1,500 bucks for like all
decked out phone but then like a company
that are trying to make it so they catch
you in there so it's like oh no it's
just fifty bucks a month like fifty
bucks a month they're like [ __ ] I got a
car payment a house payment I got a
[ __ ] phone payment like what the [ __ ]
and so it's spacing so now they have
reduced the price to replace your
battery so before used to be $79 now
it's $29 for well that's kind of cool
yeah and so they're also promising to
include a new feature in the upcoming
iOS update that will let users see the
health of their battery so that's nice
do you guys prefer to if you have the
money already do you guys prefer to just
pay something off you like that at once
instead of having to worry about
payments it depends it depends on how
huge the purchase and it depends on how
you want player taxes to yeah yeah yeah
I pick a phone or some smaller like
plays less of a role in taxes kind of it
depends on what it is cuz I just pay it
off like for my phone like I don't want
to worry about them payments I just buy
it I think it's it's whatever you want
yeah I always like payments mo money now
another thing to note here is they're
saying that Apple is not permanently or
persistently slowing down older iPhones
not all phones are affected if the
battery is healthy even if your iPhone
is affected the performance limitations
only happen when the device is
completing demanding test I don't have
any problems in my phone how old's your
sh o what do I have a seven maybe eight
ten where's that like 10 X minus seven
my name's Brady already good it's brand
new
that was a weird move maybe I just need
a new battery maybe right yeah yeah but
droid I think does the same thing now
let's talk about I have a droid and I
don't know what I have six or seven I
don't know I haven't read it but I know
that it like the new one came out and I
should feel slow yeah I had the craziest
problem Detroit that's why I changed
Apple I don't have problems per se just
slow yeah you do have a green bubble
that's a huge problem everyone's afraid
of buying like American cars have to
like it's gonna break down in a year
yeah yeah but it doesn't we've had
multiple no that's the scary thing I
think things like that have come from
like 85 to 95 and then just stuck yeah
well from an era of fault like what my
parents grew up with so they only have
like Japanese cars
and then we've owned several actually
and then we're just laughing when the
opposite German like all German so good
like now and then she had a high
everything's the same who's getting like
a recall like every two months yeah okay
the court yeah so what the hell do
people do now like two books hoverboards
bro
we're going to [ __ ] hub for public
boards what the house my Sunday this
doesn't make me want to leave a cool
Apple who cares yeah it doesn't make me
want to leave Apple yeah cuz I feel like
it's just still too convenient like all
of it work together yeah
it's also I have my like light my Wi-Fi
thing is all not anymore actually my
Apple TV
I have Apple TV watch pad macbook phone
I have everything I'm like an apple
ambassador hmm
what breaks my heart though is like I
would like years of usage for something
that's gonna be like a thousand dollars
what's a laptop 1200 so same thing and a
laptop or the cheaper one some of them
could be like three to five thousand but
I'm just saying you can get a pretty
good Mac whatever book pro flat or
whatever the hell they're called let's
say again like four years of usage out
of it I'd be pretty cool if it breaks
down I'm like fine whatever I'll go to
the next one right technology is
probably gonna be better by then but if
technology doesn't change and it's just
the same [ __ ] like a car right like most
cars besides the luxury part of it it's
pretty much the same [ __ ] you don't need
it for anything else right but if it
[ __ ] up after a year I'd be pretty
pissed yeah that's like an iPhone people
like Oh how's the ten all the cameras
better like that's it you're paying what
$500 more or something you know it's
like it's what is really nice having the
entire screen do you talk about selfie
inside do you have the accident yeah it
looks pretty sick I love
I love the fact that you're just like
covers the entire wait was it soothing
the 1000 CD people like it and I love
the things I [ __ ] love that I love it
because I used to hate doing the
thumbprint yeah and then now I just look
at it and like I don't have to put my
passwords for anything
I just know whatever you're like crime
black eyes glasses I have to take it off
like it has to see my eyes like my eyes
need to look at the phone like fun like
this it won't unlock it so whatever so
what if one somebody poke you in the eye
and you gotta call the police or
something help me and then you can't
open up your eye and it doesn't reckon
or we take your eyes you just punch in
my passcode yeah but I have your phone
and your eyes I want to test out the
chin face on it okay what if that is
your code that's a yes every I guess I
don't work without your chin face yeah
if it's detecting your eyes it's not
fair so can I take I'm at the freakin
that I I think last night and it stores
wouldn't I take a picture of you print
out that [ __ ] and then put it in front
of it yeah you can try and even try that
yesterday he took a selfie or something
and then try to do it yes or no Conner's
really do he's so precious
[Music]